hello everyone and welcome to another
very enjoyable game from round three of
this year's norway chess it's arientari
versus yanni pognishi and this is the
armageddon game their classical game
ended in a draw and this one it's uh
really really really enjoyable so let's
dive straight into it so tari with the
white pieces opens with e4
we have c5 nipple goes for the sicilian
defense we have knight to c3 d6 and now
f4 the uh close sicilian it is battari
goes for this aggressive line with f4s
he needs a win this is the armageddon we
have g6 by nipple knight to f3 and now
bishop to g7 and now bishop to b5 check
uh nipple blocks with the bishop bishop
to d7 and now bishop back to c4 so kind
of losing a tempo but
as the end result the black was forced
to develop his bishop on this uh
somewhat unfavorable square
knight to c6 just continuing development
and d3 now getting ready to develop the
dark square bishop also strengthening
the center here we have knight to a5
challenging this bishop and bishop to d2
now so here uh black can capture this
bishop at any point and keep the bishop
there but for the moment nipple keeps
them on the board with e6 uh queen to e2
saying okay i might castle king sir but
i might also castle queenside it's more
likely that kingside castles will be
played uh we have knight to e7 uh nipple
also ready to castle and now there are a
few games where a3 was played and it
kind of makes sense you're asking black
do you really want to capture here or
i'm gonna uh retreat my bishop to a2 but
in this game we have e5 and it is not as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game so here you're challenging black's
d6 spawn you're also threatening uh well
if uh
the black captures uh with the d pawn on
e5 then the c5 c5 pawn will become a
little bit weak and of course black is
not interested in uh ruining his center
but by playing e5 he also freed the f5
square for uh black's knight so this is
exactly what nipple goes for knight to
f5
we have bishop back to b5 now offering a
trade of light square bishops and now d5
so closing the center and keeping his
knight on this excellent f5 square and
although it seems like you could kick it
away with the g4 uh knights to d4 is
perfectly fine for black even though
your pawns will get the doubled uh well
there's not all that much white can do
about this for example if we trade
bishops here captures captures and now
move the knight uh yes we're attacking
the knight here but then the knight
moves and black is perfectly fine here
not a lot to worry about here so uh
instead after d5 we have bishop captures
on d7 right away queen captures and now
knight captures on d5 a temporary uh
uh pawn uh win for for white but it will
not last with e captures on d5 now we
pick up the knight on a5 and the queen
to b5 now attacking the bishop ended the
b2 pawn so bishop back to c3 defending
the pawn and now d4 chasing the bishop
further back so we can pick up the b2
pawn so bishop d2 and queen captures on
b2 nipple wins the pawn back and he's
also threatening to capture the c2 pawn
but also the rook on a1 so here we have
castles uh now the the rooks are
defending each other and now while you
could capture on c2 it's safer to maybe
just castle first so castles by black
and now uh what do you do about the c2
pawn well it's not all that easy to
defend it you could play something like
rook f not that but you could play
something like rook f the c one this
defends the pawn but then again your
rooks aren't really all that useful here
on on a1 and c1 so instead we have queen
to e4 centralizing the queen also
putting some pressure on the b7 pawn and
here nipple really has to
decide whether to capture the pawn or
not if queen captures on c2 uh there's
nothing wrong with capturing this pawn
uh if black if white captures on b7
you're gonna capture on d3 as well so
here black white will probably go for
some like rook f2 uh but uh even with
this there are no good discoveries with
this bishop and should be should be
perfectly fine for black
but it's armageddon nipple doesn't want
to waste too much time he just plays the
solid b6 and now asks why what do you
have i have this beautiful pawn chain
here
how are you
gonna well do anything about this so
here we have g4 now g4 is playable uh
knight to e3 and now bishop captures an
ether we have d captures and now you
can't go for this pawn grab uh if you
capture this you're gonna lose the c2
pawn and now there's really no way for
for white to push for anything here
black's position is extremely solid uh
you can't advance this pawn the rook is
on a1 you can't really do all that much
if you try something like f5 just to
rook e8 and the black is perfectly fine
uh so instead we have rook 8 to e1
saying that all right i'm gonna put my
rooks on the e and f file and now i'm
going to start pushing with f5 and maybe
uh e6 now the rook is no longer on a1 so
you don't have to worry about black's
dark square bishop so here
we have queen captures on c2 nipple
finally grabs this pawn
and now we have f5 so starting the
attack uh neapo is now up in material uh
but uh uh
natari has the attack and now uh nipple
plays rook f2 e8 and this is pretty much
the oldest question in chess
which rook belongs on on what file do do
you play rook rook today do you play
rook to e8 do you play this rook the e8
and uh
maybe bringing this rook would be the
safer choice you kind of want to counter
white's rooks on the enf file and also
maybe moving that rook from a8 is
definitely a good idea but we have rook
f the e8 and now uh we have e6 right
away so now it's playable there's no
rook on a1
we have queen captures on a2 neapo says
all right you have your fun on the kings
side but when all of that settles i'm
just gonna start pushing my a pawn and
win the game there's not much you can do
about this uh and the position is close
to winning for white but it's uh it
requires precision and here a move that
would achieve this for white is knight
to g5 this is important because we're
not only attacking the f7 pawn now twice
but we're also we've also freed up df
file for the rook so that will
definitely come in handy and now
you don't really have a good move if you
try f6 then knight to f7 and this is
just an amazing position for white you
have this beautiful past e pawn and
black's rooks will not have all that
much to do and if you try capturing here
then f6 just wins there's nothing you
can do either you lose the bishop or you
allow f7 check and then the rook falls
so this was in the position however uh
toddy played rook captures on e3 and now
we have f captures on e6 this is not
possible as the knight still occupies
the f file so white does not have the uh
f6 move so we have f captures on g6 and
now h6 closing up the position uh we
have g5 by tari continuing the attack
and now queen to d5 nepo is up in
material and of course he wants to trade
queens we have queen the h4 now with
ideas of capturing here but now queen to
f5
uh so what what can you play here
the problem is if you go for g captures
on h6 there's queen to g6 check and now
after the king moves we're gonna capture
on h6 as well attack the queen and the
rook here so you either trade or you
have to defend the rook somehow let's
say queen to e4 and the game continues
and this is uh still okay for white but
in the game
after this uh queen to f5 move uh we
have queen to h5 queen to h5 with the
idea
of
adding more support to this knight as
black is most definitely preparing rook
to f8 and you've cleared the h4 square
for your rook so we want to play rook to
e4 to h4 and then maybe do some damage
here along the h file so here we have
rook to fate definitely the
the best course of action
and now rook to e4 preparing rook to h4
but also maybe rook to g4 uh
it has to be considered because the king
is on the g file so if the position
opens up could be very good for white we
have rook to f6 nepo uses some
devilish trickery here because the rook
cannot be captured the queen would hang
on h5 we have rook to g4 and now comes
rook to g6 and here again nippo kind of
overestimated the position uh here uh if
uh goes knight to e5 which uh you know
is not that difficult to spot uh if you
don't spot uh the move he played first
then you you you spot your own move and
then you're like yeah this is a good
move you don't look for anything else if
he uh didn't uh
well mess up his position by playing the
mover that he did play then he would
have found knight to the e5 and this is
not great uh as there's not much that
can be done here the rook is hanging
here and if of course the knight is
captured then we're just going to
capture on g6 and that's it there's
nothing really really good for
for black here if you deliver check we
can simply move king to h1 and that's it
and on the other hand after knight to e5
if you play bishop captures an e5 which
again is possible then of course you
simply lose the queen
so the knights the e5 would have been
deadly but he played knights to h for
kind of the same idea attacks the queen
uh with the rook and the knight also
forks the queen and the rook but there's
a problem there's a move that completely
shatters uh or white's possession so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this move for nipple while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh
well you could try bishop to d4 check
first it doesn't ruin the position or
anything but there's no reason to do
this so whoever found this
congratulations is it's a beautiful
temporary uh queen sacrifice and that is
queen captures on g4 uh this is what
nepal played and it was in this position
on move 31 that arientari resigned in
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here your queen is hanging you're
down a rook and if you recapture the
queen then just rook captures on g5 and
like we said nepo is up too much
material for white to go into an end
game so after we will we see a trade
here like captures captures the knight
is attacked let's say knight f3 and now
g4 uh there's really nothing for white
to hope for here as black is up three
pawns and like we said in the middle of
the game uh black pretty much uh all
black pretty much has to do is just push
a5 a4 and that's that's uh a victory so
of course tarry knows this and he had
like a minute on the clock nipple had
some two minutes on the clock so it was
of course in this position that he
resigned the game
uh
or let me just check yeah he resigned
the game uh sometimes even though black
is winning because uh draw is enough in
armageddon sometimes player also will
draw the game but i just wanted to make
sure no he resigned here
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we still don't have the uh
real standings as the around one game
between yepo and karjakin did not happen
it will be played on on a rest day
and only then will we see the stan the
real standings but for now richard
is leading the tournament uh followed by
magnus carlsen uh but depending on how
the game plays out between niepo and and
sergey uh it could all change because if
nepal wins he gets three full points for
a classical then nipple will be leading
the tournament and if uh
karjakin wins then uh he will uh
possibly uh equalize with with uh
rapport for first place but we'll see
it's hard to predict any result in
classical match so you know we will see
what happens uh but yeah once again
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
thai had two good chances in this game
to turn it around but in armageddon uh
you know it almost almost never happens
you've seen how slippery magnus can be
in armageddon uh as he was
supposed to lose so many times but he
always somehow wiggles out as we always
say uh luck favors the strong
uh so uh once again hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank jeff
langley samuel camuy mikhail garbo john
queenie and matthew coleman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
very nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day